and we are live once again let's go
ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
welcome back
anyway y'all welcome back
on today's episode what are we talking
about I guess we're going to continue
with baby news and uh continue uh
sharing that Journey
um Britney Spears got slapped but she
might have slapped herself
The Flash was a super big bust there's
more news that came out about that
there's like a cheesy cheesy
cheeseburger there's some tech news some
thumbs up but it's always authentically
me here
[Music]
all right welcome back to beautiful wood
Griffin y'all yeah my voice was a shot
today
I said I needed to drink some water
anyways welcome back to riffing with
Griffin a weekly podcast about
everything and everything my name is
Eric Griffin uh you you know if you're
here for the first time you're like
who's this guy is that Montez yeah you
know doing a podcast I love my little
podcast
um you know we talk about I talk about
everything that's why it's riffing with
Griffin uh so come check me out here you
know sometimes it's funny sometimes it's
serious but it's always authentically me
if you're here all the time thanks for
being here you know the deal so please
hit the Subscribe button so you know
when I go live I usually go live on on
Wednesdays it's anywhere between ten and
one something around there I should pick
a specific time but you know life gets
in the way uh you know it's here I'm on
Twitch twitch daily playing games I play
a lot of Call of Duty I play a lot of
Diablo I love Diablo so check that out
and on patreon now we got content is
going up weekly I haven't done this
week's but uh this is going to be uh
riff it spoiling with Griffin that's
gonna be the one of the major things on
my patreon is I'm gonna spoil oil stuff
so you know like for instance the last
episode uh on spoiling with Griffin
spoiler alert we'll come up with a
better name we'll figure it out but
um it was all about the Black Mirror
episodes I won Episode by episode and I
just talked about it so maybe you don't
even want to watch a show or you don't
care if you hear the ending or whatever
then you're gonna come be a part of my
patreon go to spoiling with Griffin
spoiler alert uh at the patreon uh
patreon.com Eric Griffin the links in
the bio and links in down here in the
description so and so this next one I'm
gonna do all about Idol the the crazy
weekend you know Johnny Depp's daughter
show
we're just gonna I'm just gonna go into
depth about that because that show was
bananas so there is finally some real
patreon content going up so make sure
you check me out on there guys
um
today's episode today's episode is
brought to you by new sponsor Factor
factor factor meals man I want to thank
them for being a sponsor factor is
America's number one ready to eat meal
kit can help you fuel up fast with
flavorful and nutritious Ready-to-Eat
meals delivered straight to your door
head to factormeals.com
griffin50 and use code Griffin 50 to get
50 off that's code Griffin 50 at
factorymeals.com50 to get 50
off thanks to factor for being a sponsor
all right welcome uh everybody welcome
back to uh
riffle with a Griff Hall
um what's going on here uh
I guess we're gonna start every episode
with like you know I guess we're not
gonna start every episode with baby news
but it is what it is you know I think
it's like a little early you know we got
this we got the the I talked about it
last week if you don't know Rachel's
pregnant and you know here we are we're
at like 11 something weeks almost 12
weeks uh you know it's still early to
tell people but it's like it is what it
is I was just I don't know why we just
spent we just
we just doing it you know Rachel's not
here right now she's at her parents
she's like spending time with her mom
too which is great
um so
yeah man it's uh very exciting I'm
scared excited you know and it's just
what a journey you go on uh watching a
you know a person you know what happens
to oh man so much things happen to women
armors are getting numb and
constipated they have to drink a lot of
water the the nausea and all this it's
so it's so crazy so like you know when
you read about it or you talk to anybody
that's been pregnant or anybody that's
had kids as you know it's like the first
trimester is the hardest time and I
think also it's like that's your if you
think about it it makes sense like your
body's preparing for this like magical
process and so it's like it's got to
make room it's like oh let's prepare
this womb and let's get the hormones are
flowing so everybody's like
you know it's tough it's really tough
and so you know we're going through that
you know what I mean
um
yeah I don't even know what else to even
say I don't know it's like as a dude
what are you supposed to do you know
what I mean you know you just like do
what you do like she like got mad like I
was the other day I was playing video my
video games I'm streaming on Twitch you
know which I do daily
air Griffin gaming on Twitch and so I
didn't hear her so like she ordered some
bagels you know because she likes to
have a bagel in the morning so she
ordered some bagels and they delivered
them and they're sitting at the front
door right they I didn't hear you know
I'm busy and she's then I just I I
during a quiet moment of the game I hear
somebody yelling and she's yelling at me
now the bagels are here
it's something like I was like oh man so
tell my stream hold on guys I'll be
right back I go up there and she's just
like you know fuming at me that
Bangladesh of course she put extra on it
that bagels have been sitting out there
for two and a half hours I look at the
phone because I see the when we Buzz
people and I I get the phone calls too
it's like it's a you know so I see and I
was like it was like 20 minutes ago
right so then I just but you know what
you you can't like that's the thing you
learn a lot of patience uh you have to
exercise a lot of patience when you're
uh you know your dutiful husband right
so I walk up and she's you know you know
okay yeah I gotta say it I said I got
the bagels you know is there anything
else you need and she's like I have a
headache now and you know she's going in
and I just said is there
anything else you need you know
no
you know you know that I just like went
downstairs I I got I knew some I knew
some couple things she needed so I got
him I brought him back up and I gave it
to her just like is there anything else
you need she's like I need a better
attitude from you
so then I smiled I went like this is
there anything else you need
you know it's a fun process you know
what I mean it's like
so again you know
we're going through this little you know
so let's like everybody keep your
fingers crossed for the uh
um
because we took all the tests and stuff
and then like you know the next because
we go to a I think we go to a doctor's
appointment next week and next week it's
like you find out the gender and you
find out if there's anything wrong or if
everything's perfect you know what I
mean it's like uh so that's and I get
now why people don't say anything but
it's like you know what I'm you know I'm
I'm going through this journey so if
anybody else is going through this
journey or been through this journey you
know where we're at and uh you know I'm
sharing this experience with you uh you
know it's tough but it is what it is so
thank you for always being here and all
the people that have been very
supportive on the way
um
so I don't know and then Rachel's off
work right now too so she's been on
leave you know she's got they actually
passed a law in California for pregnant
women they it's like I didn't even know
that this was a thing you know what I
should actually I should be talking
about that
um where is this uh uh pregnant women
law in California uh
um let's see
um yeah there's some they just passed
this the other day
I gotta find it wait let me find this
um
pregnant long California pregnancy and
maternity leave laws here it is right
here this is interesting so California
pregnancy and maternity leave laws
uh let's see taking leave during
pregnancy disability it's like
disability leave the employer has five
or more employees their employer is
disabled by pregnancy childbirth or
medical conditions related to pregnancy
or childbirth you could take leave for
that so she's taking she took leave from
work because she's like she's so
nauseous and all that you know what I
mean
and now and you can take leave for baby
bonding so it's like you could take
leave from she took leave from work
um you know so that's pretty cool
that they that even they even allowed
that so she was like worried about it I
was like you don't really gotta you know
you don't gotta worry about it I don't
know if she's even Gonna Wanna continue
working I don't know I told her it's up
to her it's like if you don't want if
you don't want to do it but you know she
she like Rachel's a visual merchandiser
you know and so it's like she's the one
visual merchandiser at her Target store
you know and if you don't know what
visual merchandise it is she's the one
like you know she sets up the displays
and you know it's like oh we got to move
this stuff here and she like you know
it's all all it's like it's almost like
interior decorating for the store uh you
know all you know she gets she gets to
order stuff oh we need shells for this
and so you know that's what she wants
she what she wanted to do she I think
she wants to like she wants to do it at
like a more like upscale fancy store but
you need experience and so Target's a
great company to get that experience uh
you know because then she can move to
other stores if she wanted to like say
we move or something like that and then
you go you build up this experience then
you go to whatever store you want to be
like oh yeah I was a visual merchandise
or a target for three years or whatever
it is like that uh but I don't know she
may just decide ah I want to be a
stay-at-home mom so either way it's fine
I know all the troll haters think
they're getting to me they're like oh
you get your girl at Target you making
your girl work into the world are you
broke
you know what's funny this is the funny
part so it was Rachel's a gold digger so
that was the The Narrative from the
trolls and the comments it was like you
know because like you know I like to
read the comments I read the comments
for the thing so I see them so I know
you got I know you guys are like man
don't give the trolls any uh steam
Griffin it's like I'm just saying I read
the comments on the uh for the podcast
so it doesn't matter but anyways in the
beginning it was uh you're she's a gold
digger watch out man you know she's only
with you for your money
unknownst to you she been working this
whole time so then
now you find out where she works and now
that's a thing we she and I she laughed
about it so much because she said the
same thing she was like oh my God so
what am I am I a gold digger or or what
is it which one do you want so it's just
it's just interesting like I shouldn't I
should label the podcast I'm busy
podcasting and gaming while my wife
slaves away at Target
I should make that
I should make that the thing so but
anyways
she get is great she got great Insurance
she got like you know but I probably got
to put her on my sag Insurance actually
I don't know that's a whole thing too
when you get when you're having babies
and stuff you got to worry about like
where's like the insurance and like who
how long what what it covers and
man you know you don't know about what
you need until you actually need it and
then you look and see like your
insurance coverage and all that kind of
stuff isn't it it's funny that like it
is until something happens to you that
you look and you go wait a minute this
isn't even covered or you're like oh wow
I didn't know I had to pay this much of
a deductible or what what what what is
it the co-pay or whatever it is like
that so it's like it's funny man
insurance is one of those things that
you know you hope you don't use it but
you want to have it when you need it
right so it's like but I do suggest
people check in on their coverage
uh you know what I mean but yeah I see a
comments number read the comments so
anyways thanks for the people being live
on chat yeah Jose murga said How's she a
gold digger but she has her own job I
know that's what I'm saying that's my
that's my whole point but it's like you
know there there's the professional
trolls out there uh who like they think
this is a thing you know what I mean
guys go attack him about Target it's
like I'm super proud of my wife uh uh
that she works hard and really loves her
job she like loves her job she this is
what I like this is what she'll do man
it's so funny she'll take pictures right
I said how was work today and she'd be
like oh my God I did this this display
and this and that she said you want to
see the pictures
I'm like not really but I'm like okay
babe let me see and then she'll go
through the pictures like all right this
is women's sportswear this is uh oh this
baby stuff this was like uh oh the pride
stuff and so she was talking to me about
all that remember all that stuff that
was happening at Target about like
people were coming in about the Pride
and where they should put it so she was
knee-deep in that because she had to
like set it up and then move it and then
like you know some places in La people
didn't care but they're I'm sure like
she was saying
like it must be terrible like to work at
some place a Target in like a place
where this was like a big deal because
then it's like oh man take this down
take that down so you know
it's funny
uh
anyways let's go to the comments
we do have some interesting comments
this week and if you you know you
comment like I said I do skim through
the comments and see the ones that I I I
I want so Gage three three one one he
put like a bunch of comments but he was
talking about the nfts because remember
last week I was talking about nfts and
it's like this seems like a big ass scam
and he said he wanted to give his
thoughts on nfts in a blockchain in
general because I think it's being
really overlooked with all the scams
that transpired but if it's done in the
right way it allows creators like
yourself a much better experience
for some background blah blah blah
nobody cares about that he's a computer
science graduate kudos to you nfts are
essentially just a way of creators like
yourself another way to monetize your
content whether it be pictures art
videos Etc
um yeah okay this is the thing though
dude like so
I mean
yeah that's the scam the scam is finding
another way okay how about this this
scam is
how do you actually quantify
the value
so you're saying I own a picture right
okay
but like you could just Google the
picture like that picture that Justin
Bieber owns
I could just go to Google show me the
picture that Justin Bieber owns and it
comes up on my screen I can print I can
go to Kinkos make a 20 by 20 frame it
and put it on my wall I own it now you
know what I mean like the thing is the
only way this really means anything to
anyone it's manufactured value the only
reason why it would mean anything to
anyone if the technology was in a way
that like if I tried to Google that
picture it had a watermark on it and
instead owned by Justin Bieber and I
couldn't then okay maybe but you're
saying okay it makes a way for people to
want yeah but that's so that's like only
fans or you know patreon or being a
YouTube member or being a twitch
subscriber which you can at Eric Griffin
gaming and be a YouTube member here at
YouTube at Eric Griffin at Griffin with
Griffin but anyways you know it's like
you have to have a value you know what
I'm saying it's like we have to say like
die diamonds for instance we have
decided that diamonds are valuable
are they really
but we've decided that they are because
they're rare they say they're rare So if
something's rare
and there's a something you can use it
for like put it on a ring that only one
person can have only one person can have
this diamond
the nft would be like
you have the diamond and then anybody
else can also have
the diamond it looks just you know
I I don't know if I'm even making sense
but it just
I don't I think it's a scam I get what
you're saying why how you can use it but
it's a scam because
it's just manufactured value that we've
started to realize has no value it has
zero value because
I can just download the picture if you
understand what I'm saying
um let's see what else we got here uh I
love these kind of comments J JD Bush
3982 great podcast
thank you all right
um I I had some good ones where are they
let's say
that seems stupid oh let's see
no I don't like that one
uh
let's see mindset ccg said tiny purse is
only for one purpose to carry the NFC
chip from your card so you could just
tap and go
if you remember they had that Speck of
salt sized purse that was 63 000 from
last week so you just like hold that up
to the thing it's a that's silly a lot
of congratulations from people thank you
very much Chandler Pearson 9853 CGI was
bad in Indy but I loved it I'm I
embodied what I think of when I think of
classic Indiana Jones movies if they
don't blank it up around oh you know
yeah I agree I mean yeah I mean the
Indiana Jones movie was just I'm
nostalgic so I wanted to watch it you
know I I just and and here's my thoughts
I'm glad you brought this up uh that
that comment I'm glad I saw that comment
here's the real issue about CG about the
CGI in Indiana Jones
if this were to happen say two years ago
let's say two years ago they came out
with this Indiana Jones and we saw this
scene of young Indiana Jones uh that
they made we would be really Amazed by
it we would have been like wow this is
great CGI is a little choppy at some
points but we were like man this is like
wow where's the future going with this
we might have had a better feeling about
it but because
the whole thing about AI right now the
whole like bad feelings we have about Ai
and the writers strike about AI you know
the the AI element of it and and how
everybody's scared about AI now when we
look at that we go uh oh what are they
doing are they taking actors jobs uh you
know now we had this sort of like
negative connotation to it that I think
has which was bad for one flash which is
bad for
um
this for Indiana Jones so
let's see uh
uh let okay pork chop Express 6890 I
knew the flash wasn't gonna be good
which is why I didn't see it just like
how I feel I will not see Constantine 2
with Keanu Reeves ooh this is going to
be a Constantine too I actually really
like that movie though
um anyways he it goes he goes on and on
and on so but uh yeah man I I know what
you mean you know sometimes you but you
know what if you're into the genre and
you just go see it even if it's good or
bad what I'm hearing is Mission
Impossible new Mission Impossible is so
good so I can't wait to go see that and
review that one
um let's see what else we got more
congrats
f f h y n x 87 congrats big dog and may
I share after 11ish weeks is appropriate
as a new dad to a six month old it's an
amazing process thank you and I will
keep you uh in the loop guys
Nate Dogg
gg671 said the vocals were on point
today Griffin I know sometimes they're
good sometimes they bad you know what I
mean but it's always live
um yeah anyways well that's all the
comments guys thank you for your
comments thank you for sharing thanks
for being here you know
I haven't seen spider verse yet Sean
Carroll on the YouTube chat uh I I have
to you know it's funny I don't know I
just haven't had the the I haven't I
haven't I guess I when I go out of town
is when I see movies now especially now
because Rachel just likes me around you
know so I'll go do my sets and in
Hollywood go do my podcasting and then
you know come back and then here I am
with the uh you know
you know what I mean so and then I'm
trying to like I've been cooking too I
got to get back to kitchen with Griffin
so I've been cooking for her because she
doesn't like a lot of spices and then
and then it's also more healthy and I
don't use butter and all this kind of
stuff so I'm feeling better so I'm
cooking and then I got to start my
exercise regimen again so I got my my
rowing machine I gotta I gotta like do
that more I really gotta just do it
every day just to get some movement
15-20 minutes is all you need
but I want to do some like real I need
to find like a real close place that I
can go to to get like some training two
times a week you know get some lifting
in because I do it better when I have
somebody like there with me going do
this do that so I'm looking to do that
because you know I want to be I want to
be healthy I want to be able to lift my
kid up I want to be able to like you
know be able to I Wanna I don't want to
feel winded you know so it's like I
gotta get good sleep I gotta eat right
and I gotta exercise
um it's just you know and I gotta just
make it something that I need to do and
want to do but you know you get
comfortable and lazy it's so I mean
that's really the thing all this talk
about obesity and all this talk about
health and body positivity and all like
cut the noise cut all the nonsense we
know individually we know we're looking
at ourselves and we're like man I'm busy
I I get tired I'm I'm I just I'm
generally lazy about certain things and
we all feel that we all don't want to
like we all don't like oh man I can't
eat the things I want to eat you know we
all feel that way
you know we all feel that way and so
that's really I think a majority of the
issue is just
changing your lifestyle and making it
stick
that's what it is you know
so
I select 101 thank you man uh he said
review past lives when you get a chance
past lives at a show where's that show
on
you know it's like you want to be a fit
Dad yeah somebody said I feel you on the
fit dad goals yeah you know it's hard
now you're like now it's not even about
me anymore you know it's like it's about
someone else so
you know it is what it is
uh anyways so that's that so before we
go on uh let's one more shout out to our
um
sponsor the show are great new sponsors
factor and this is actually a good time
to talk about this I've actually tried
Factor before
um I've had it come and it's actually
really great really tasty and you could
get a really good healthy option and
it's great portion control
um that's really the thing that I think
about when you get these food plans when
you get these meal kits I mean the
hardest thing is that when you go to
restaurants and stuff you eat too much
and then they have too many ingredients
that are not good for you and then you
end up it's all about portion control
you you more you eat more so you gain
more you take in more calories you get
fat you got to get something like this a
meal plan the factor is great for that
if you're too busy with summer plants to
cook but you want to make your eating
eating well you want to eat well I'm
telling you I had some delicious Factor
stuff man like because you could pick
like paleo or you could pick different
meal plans so man I was like oh I I
loved it and so I'm actually using it
gonna I'm using it now because it's like
I want to cook and and there's times
when you just want to have a small meal
boom factor is perfect for that ready to
fill your best while making the most of
your summer Adventures stick to your
Wellness goals with premium ready to eat
meals featuring high quality ingredients
such as broccoli leeks and asparagus
love the vegetables there treat yourself
to a 34 plus weekly restaurant quality
options like bruschetta shrimp Rosado
Green Goddess chicken grilled Steakhouse
filet mignon the steak was delicious
I'm just thinking about it right now I'm
freaking hungry
all right too busy running around during
the day to think about lunch keep your
energy up lunch to go effortless
wholesome meals like grain bowls salad
topic listen the the quality I factor is
fantastic take it from me I highly
recommend it all right so head to
factorymeals.com
griffin50 5-0 Griffin fifty five zero
and used code Griffin 50 to get 50 off
that's Griffin that's code Griffin 50 at
factor meals.com griffin50 to get 50 off
hey just try it try it one time you're
gonna get 50 off I'm telling you you're
gonna save money you're gonna have
portion control you're gonna eat healthy
it's completely worth it doesn't hurt to
try it once Factor thank you
all right guys let's get to the story of
the week I'm not even gonna keep you
waiting on this one
um
so
Britney Spears
um
man
I I don't even know what to think about
this one here so I don't know if you I
know you guys heard the story so when it
first came out it was this you know oh I
wish I had the video oh man I should you
know what am I talking about of course I
mean that's exactly what I should should
have right let me look it up Brittany
gets slapped
let's go to the video okay let me just
pull up some video footage here
uh let's see if I got it here's one so
you know so so she's in Vegas and she
sees this uh
she had she she sees this um
um what do you call it
um
the the new rookie of the you know
rookie one number one pick Victor buen
bin yamba you know he's from
um
um San Antonio Spurs and he's walking in
Vegas and then you know Britney walks up
to him and she gets slapped you know she
tries to
wait this isn't this is like the
breakfast clubs page you know we don't
want that hold up let me find this and
she walks up to him to try to like she's
run you can see her running after him
and she's like hey Victor whatever she's
saying and then the security guard like
whoa whoa whoa you know what I mean what
you doing and then you know it looks as
if the security guard smacks her in the
face
so
but after a week and the um the the
police reviewing the tape
it turns out that it looks like actually
he just the guy just moved her hand and
it looks like Britney Spears slapped
herself
you know but I mean
you talk about some big strong ass
security guard uh
you know what I mean so I don't know
where's they're not showing the
I can't get the video it's so dumb
sometimes Google is helpful sometimes
it's not but anyways you go find it you
know so what did I why am I bringing
this up you know I was trying to find a
video that's why I feel like I'm
Meandering right now but I mean it's you
know it's big news you know but I the
thing that made me think of is like man
what how how how the mighty have fallen
right
you know what I mean it's like
you know there was a time when Britney
Spears was probably the most famous
person on the planet like in the top
five you know top 10 at most at least
you know what I'm saying but it's like
she was that famous like we all and then
even recently with all her things we
know who Britney Spears is now she's
just a part of like we oh man Britney
Spears we know some whatever story we
know how long she's been in the public
eye we know her songs anybody could say
they they know a Britney Spears song He
said hey do you know Britney Spears
songs and you know they would be like
oops I did it again or one of her songs
you know and and here she is just in
Vegas you know we see her now she looks
like a crazy Auntie you know what I mean
like it's like
you know the image we have of her is
always going to be school school dress
you know dancing and singing and you
know a snake kissing Madonna at the
Grammys like there's a image of Britney
Spears that is like being diluted
because of all the things we know now
you know she was in a conservatorship
for 13 years like that's crazy to me
when I think about it 13 years she
wasn't controlling her own life so now
she is so it's not it's kind of a sad
Tale
if they do a dock on Brittany I mean
it's it's not gonna What's it gonna be
it's like so fascinating to like where
she went to where she is now and that
kind of Fame is like so crazy right so
here's Britney Spears who is now this
sort of like weird figure you know like
if you saw her you'd be like oh hey you
know what I mean and then you see her on
Instagram sort of acting crazy and it's
like it could be just trolling for all
we know but then you know fans they're
calling the police you know you got to
get over there you know what I mean like
she was crazy on Instagram so you know
they doing Wellness checks on her and
stuff like that so it's just a crazy
situation so what I'm saying is
back in the day
If Britney Spears is walking in Vegas
with her three bodyguards and she sees
Victor Juan benyamba and she sees
somebody she wants to go say hi to she
would be like this because first of all
she got like two or three handlers she
got the the people her security security
she got her assistant maybe the
publicist is with her she got an
Entourage right
she would tell the Entourage yo
hey um assistant go you know go go check
go say hi to um that guy tell him I want
to say hi then the assistant would run
over there and be like hey hi hi
um so sorry
um I'm I'm Britney's assistant
um she's right over there she would love
to just say Hi and then he would be like
oh what Britney Spears yeah security be
like yo Britney Spears wants to say hi
dude he would be like all right cool and
then they would be like they would you
know the hotel would be like oh let me
put you guys in this room and then they
would go and freaking it would be a
great thing it'd be a picture moment and
it would be like you know Brittany and
Victor are saying hi right that's how it
would be
you know but Britney's like different
now she's like like a regular ass chick
running after the dude in the hotel yeah
oh my God what's up
I'm thinking you know what I mean and
then she like tries to grab the dude and
then
security is like yo yo yo white girl you
know what I mean it's like we're in
Vegas you don't know what's going on you
know what I mean it's it's like that's
just how it goes
um
even if it was reverse what if Victor
won't be Yambo he like
grew up loving Britney Spears you know
what I mean when he was five it was like
oh man strong yeah whatever you know I
don't know if that would be a thing for
him but it could be
he could be walking with his dudes like
yo hold up is that Britney Spears
yo and if he like his big ass ran over
and was like Britney you know I'm sure
her bodyguards would have like I don't
know if she even has bodyguards anymore
they would have been like yo back up
dude it would have been the whole thing
so I mean it's just it's just really
about how Fame what it does to you and
you know what's going on
it's just like it's crazy and then of
course
she again she's still famous but not now
she's not famous for her art and for her
Talent she's famous for being Britney
Spears so this became a big news story
and you know how these people are they
need something to talk about you know uh
they need something so they have the
video it looks like oh she got slapped
you know so then it was like that's it
nobody everybody ran with it even though
they had the video Even though I think
all these news outlets saw and examined
it themselves and was like well actually
she didn't really get slapped the guy
just like
she was trying to touch their client and
the poop guy was like no no no you know
and then her hand she remember hit
herself you know what I mean
but it's like
I mean what are you supposed to do man
that's how famous she is
she's so famous that like you know
it all every it all became about her so
you know it's a crazy thing man
um
yeah
but see like somebody said in the chat
if the Kardashians I don't think so
here's the thing though like if if
Courtney
would have ran up
if one of the if one of the like other
Kardashians you know so you got Kim like
Kim Kardashian not running up to Victor
one but Yama right first of all she's
like 411 okay
she's 411 this way and that way with the
booty you know so she would have like
ran like Kim Kardashian would have ran
over she would first that's what I'm
trying to say there's no way Kim
Kardashian runs over to this guy she got
like 85 people around her at all times
when she's walking people are putting
makeup on her she would have just sent a
minion over and the minion would have
done what I said earlier you know it
would have just been like that now if it
was Kendall
right if it was Kendall who's probably
going to be dating this dude in like you
know a month
you know what I mean she gonna be like
yeah it was still would have been the
same thing somebody bodyguard or one of
her friends would have been over and
like hey excuse me bodyguard
um hi I'm with Kendall Kendall Jenner
you know and then they probably would
have no no and then next thing you know
you know it's like I get it when you see
somebody
you see you're out and you and you're
like famous and you see somebody famous
and you're like oh two famous people
should be like hey what's up but it's
like don't you're just another person it
it it's it's such a it's such a weird
thing right
uh it's just it's just weird but I do
feel for Britney Spears I think she's
gotten a lot of
I think she's getting a lot of undue
attention it's kind of like hey just let
the lady live you know like like who
knows how much money she has left you
know they they just were taking
advantage of her I just hope that she
could just live her life out in
happiness you know
it just yeah I don't like this
I don't like the image that's
put out even by her and then how it's
like digested by the media it's it's
coming across like Britney's just this
crazy woman you know
and my heart goes out to her it's like
she hasn't seen like according to
reports she hasn't seen her son and Sons
in a couple years I mean how much how
much how must this affect them you know
and
you know she's just like this person
just trying to like live her life
outside this conservative ship and just
like with her husband with her husband
and I just oh man I don't know man it's
just like it's a cautionary tale is
scary but like here's a question I ask
all of you in chat
and all of you listening on Apple and
all the places you listen is if you want
to comment my question is this
would you rather
live your personal regular life now not
that your life is bad
but if you could live a Britney Spears
life
knowing all the fame and fortune that
she achieved but then it ends up were
you a crazy Auntie right now getting
slapped by security would you do that or
would you keep your life
is there something in you to be like
well because you would think well I
could do it I'm gonna do it better you
know let's take the conservatorship out
though forget like you wouldn't be in a
conservatorship but you still ended up
like
a crazy Auntie running through Vegas
okay
it's like do do you want to end up like
that or do you want your life are you do
you want to live the life she had where
she was like super famous Super Rich
going on tour meeting people getting her
heart broke by Justin Timberlake all the
things that that went on or she broke
his heart I don't know whichever one it
was you know
um would you like that or would you want
your regular life I mean I don't know I
see a lot of people chat say regular
life regular life but you know I don't
know there might be some people who are
like ah man I would have wanted to do
that some people want fame and fortune
like do you is Fame and Fortune
worth ending up like this that's what
you have to ask yourself because she's
still Rich I'm sure she's still got
plenty of money she's living in you know
and but it's like you know do you want
all that attention it's crazy so anyways
good luck to Brittany I hope everything
works out for her
um you know
all right guys as I said uh
earlier
there was a little bit about the flash
man so
as I you know I reviewed the flash last
week and so now as the dust settles
Warner Brothers expects a 200 million
dollar loss
making it the biggest superhero box
office failure
man
that's a lot
but the D the DCU the DC Universe or DC
Studios whatever they're calling it now
Mandarin shambles man
and I think that James Gunn has not made
a great start of this I think there's
too much press I think this they they're
not controlling the narrative
now
is it because
Ezra Miller
was dealing with whatever he was dealing
with is that a part of it yes and no I
think it's nuanced my favorite word and
I'll tell you what it is
look
I don't care
how much special effects
how spectacular a movie looks
when it boils down to it you gotta have
a good story you gotta have good acting
period okay like that is the recipe for
huge success
you gotta have a great story and one of
the and then and then the third thing on
the list will be how the movie looks
okay but you gotta have two out of the
three so acting story visuals if you
have two out of the three I think you
have the recipe for a great movie or at
least a successful movie
in flash it was terrible acting
okay terrible story great special
effects and with this but you know
occasionally you saw like the digital of
uh when it was the doubles
but look honestly I think Ezra Miller
was trying too hard to be funny
and I think that that performance
with this like sort of like blah story
that we didn't really care about
it it just because I think this dude is
a great actor
and but a great actor can't make Trash
material
they can't they can only do so much okay
forget superhero movie or not any movie
my my favorite superhero movie moment is
when
in end game when Tony Stark it's in the
early on in the movie they've you know
Captain Marvel has rescued Tony Stark
and the blue chick
and they're you know in a room
discussing what happened and Tony Stark
is just emaciated with you know he's
because he's been lost in space for
months you know what I mean and he's
furious with Captain America he's
furious with him
that scene
I was like wow this is a great scene for
a freaking superhero movie but it was
passionate and his performance was
believable and you were like yeah
Captain America this is your fault you
know because of his performance but it
was great material
we it was great build up there was
nothing like that in Flash they were
trying to manufacture this you know
always trying to save his mom and all
this right but it just was like it they
didn't pull it off so all I'm saying is
you got to have a great story a decent
story that we could follow and we could
care about and then you have to have
great performances you have to have
actors that really are they they
understand their craft and emotions and
and how to convey things and then if you
have great visuals if you have all three
of those that's a recipe for a fantastic
movie like the first avatar or Titanic
or just think of any great movie you've
ever seen it probably was you like
that's why Tom Cruise is Tom Cruise does
so well man because
Tom Cruise is a great actor I believe
him every time okay I believe him he's a
great actor
the stories are great and the special
effects are great recipe for a fantastic
movie experience
you know
so we gotta you know and I think that
this movie fell short in two major
categories
um and so you have this big loss so you
know
shout out I hope I hope oh and by the
way like like I say like I feel like the
the MCU universe and MCU but yeah MCU
got issues too oh man we could go on and
on about them too but
I don't think James Gunn is starting off
strong here man you can't come out and
talk about this is the greatest
superhero movie ever
and because we believe you you know we
we we trust James Gunn okay we trust the
movies that he's made you know what I
mean we trust his voice and so when he
said that now we realize you're just a
corporate hack dude you just out here
trying to now you're just a company man
you know it would have been better for
him not to say anything because I
literally went to go see it because of
that quote I was like oh what you know
he he launched that because he was he
was a corporate man he's the head of the
studio and he's trying to make money
they know that movie was trash they
tried to fix it so many times and then
so
Ezra Miller his performance and the
movie the things I said about the movie
it wasn't enough to now re forget his
off the screen stuff
Tom Cruise is so good we don't even care
that he's in a Scientology nobody even
cares
no one cares
Scientology
let's let's not even get into it but
look it up
like
if Ezra Miller was in Scientology oh man
that no it would be even worse for him
right
it's just got to be
it's just got to be good okay
all right so it wasn't
all right let's move on
so
Tech news which I love to talk about
these days
um here's a great story scientists in
Japan have developed experimental tooth
growing drug
I mean wow where are we headed in
society right now man right we are now
growing teeth
uh would you want to do that
they made a tooth growing drug in
reality in the near future following
recent promising research in animals the
group is planning to conduct small-scale
human Trials of the drugs starting next
year
should everything go well the treatment
could reach public by the end of the
decade you know
man
it makes you think when you come out
with a certain thing to help a certain
type of flu in nine months you go wow
and then now they're trying to grow
teeth but it's going to take
2023 it's going to take seven years it's
going to take five to seven years to
grow teeth
hey I mean what do you think would you
do this I mean and where does this lead
this is what it makes me think about it
makes me think about where are we going
it's like man this feels suspiciously
like cloning you know what I mean or
like the in that vein of Technology
because I hope hopefully we get to that
point you know where like you could grow
a heart for someone you could grow
intestines or whatever people need you
know lungs uh you know all the things
you know but then you know then we're
gonna do we have the discussion of
overpopulation and what's going to
happen I think that like when it gets to
that point that science and health get
to a point where
we could really improve the human body I
think you're going to have to petition
for it that's what I think should happen
you should have to petition so let's say
your lungs have are given now you got
lung cancer and you got to get new lungs
you need a lung transplant well then I
think it's like okay
you go
and then they go why oh you were smoking
oh yeah yeah yeah
um
sorry
you know you get the old treatment
because you did this to yourself
you know uh as opposed to someone else
would say got into an accident and their
lungs collapsed or you know or or like
there's some some degenerative thing
that you know they can fix that I don't
know are you living a good life are you
contributing to society like maybe it's
gonna get to that because of
overpopulation or something I don't know
but it's like growing teeth is just the
start of like what else
you know growing teeth like somebody's
arm gets severed in a car accident it's
like oh well don't worry we got to just
take this arm pill and then you're
growing back your arm like Deadpool you
know uh who know like where is it where
are we headed I mean it's really
exciting times in technology right now I
mean as much talk as people have about
the AI and how scary it is I think it's
gonna be like the future of helping
people you know live and
and and do things man and so and you
look at the tech for health and science
I mean man there's all kinds of stories
like this man of you know we're we're
growing where where they even there's so
much talk about like you know you have
these surrogate moms now they're talking
about well I think they could make a
machine where they could do it in a
machine you know you put you know you
put the baby the baby stuff in this
machine and then now they're just
monitoring it you know like like a
little microwave you know what I mean so
instead of being inside a woman you
could just like you know you go to like
you have like your little babies your
little baby oven you know and you open
it up and you guys are standing there
looking at your baby growing inside this
little oven you know and then it goes
Bing you know what I mean then it's done
and you take it out you know but it's
monitoring all the vitals it's making
sure it's being fed it's like you know
you're you know that's what you have to
do so it'll be like a little baby
machine and you have to like put you
know uh whatever the elixir of uh baby
stuff you know inside the machine and
you know
I don't know it's just
where's the future going man
somebody said what if the teeth don't
stop growing
well that's probably what they're going
to test out or what if it grows too fast
but but I think that it's going to be
it's gonna it's gonna like rejuvenate
your cavity area that's gonna make the
tooth grow again and so it's just gonna
grow at whatever Pace teeth grow but
when do teeth stop growing that is a
good question how are they going to stop
it from growing so what if like you have
to just now you got to go to the dentist
to shave your tooth out because it keeps
growing that'd be crazy
but they need to I like that they're
doing it for animals too because I don't
know how many people my buddy his cat
broke its tooth and he had to go pay
like a crazy amount of money to for
dental care for his cat more than a
human so it's like that that's a racket
right there by the way freaking pet care
but anyways that'll we'll save that for
a completely different episode all right
let's go oh man we're getting running
out of time I got to go to all this
stuff all right this one I thought was
this is one of the stories I thought was
funny man
so in Canada all right so in Canada the
thumbs up emoji is an official contract
agreement agreement Canadian court rules
so apparently
you know this article said you better
think twice before responding so if
you're texting and you're doing a deal
and somebody says hey man do you uh you
know
I want this amount of money you okay
with that and if somebody sends you the
thumbs up they're saying yes I'm okay
with that and you have to follow through
and then if you go away I just sign a
contract now
this is so forward thinking in my
opinion this is very forward thinking
this is how people communicate
old school ways was you had a contract
you signed it or really old school was a
handshake agreement we shook hands and
if you had Witnesses shaking hands and
people yeah well I saw them Shake I saw
them discuss it that might be in court
people be like well I saw it but then it
became a thing was like well you have to
have a signed signature you got to have
a contract you got to have a contract
what is some people communicate now we
all communicate by text you know so it's
like boom thumbs up I mean this is like
when you like going out on a date with
someone or you're flirting with a girl
or your little guy but either way and
you know and you're like yo I want to do
this this and this and you want to do
this this and this you okay with this
get that thumbs up
get the thumbs up man it's gonna be like
a notary now thumbs up you know because
then when that person starts to go oh
like I had never said I was okay with
this and whatever you could be like yo
yo yo yo yo yo remember the here's me
saying I want to do this and there's you
saying thumbs up so it's like very
interesting it's like is this the future
but I think like I said again I do think
it's Forward Thinking I do think it's
like
you know when you like I don't know if
you've ever signed a contract uh I've
signed virtually signed contracts now so
it comes to your computer you know that
they take it to like that Acrobat Reader
thing and it's at the bottom it says
sign and you just click that and because
you clicked it and you wrote your name
and sent it that's a legal agreement so
this sort of thing is already happening
so I thought that was uh I thought that
was interesting
it was like is that like what do you
guys think of that you know you think
Thumbs Up Is Enough
you know maybe you young people are
gonna say yeah that's enough last story
in fat news
fat news is back check this out Burger
King in Thailand got rid of the meat
and they made a burger with 20 slices of
cheese
look at this guy eating this 20 slices
of cheese at Burger King you kidding me
what
sorry guys this is like
I don't know why
I don't know why it's doing this
wait let me get it 20 slices of cheese
this is when you're by yourself I don't
have a Jamie
oh
you know it's like this is when you this
is when you need some oh my God it keeps
this the computer asks you so many
questions now
oh my God this is crazy
like this when you just look I'm trying
to show you guys how nasty this thing
looks man this this thing is like
here we go here we go I'll just do it
like this
what whatever it's just it's not gonna
work here we go let me just do this
so many pictures of it but look at that
I mean God damn that seems nasty
like 20 slices of cheese like I don't
mind getting like some sliced cheese and
I'll have like a couple but 20. 20
slices of cheese like are you kidding me
um that just that really just seems like
a lot
[Music]
um
yeah I don't know 20 slices of cheese
y'all so anyways guys as I always say
thank you for watching thank you for
watching we're from wood Griffin
um you know be a subscriber you know we
got a lot of um
we got a lot of stuff coming
um follow me you know I'm on Twitch
daily be on Twitch in a little while
after this Eric Griffin gaming and then
also on Twitch I go live
to do my patreon content
which is
spoiling with Griffin so the next
episode I'm going to do this week for
patreon is I'm gonna go through idle the
max series with the weekend what a crazy
freaking show that was so I got it so if
you didn't want to watch it or you did
watch it and you want to hear me go into
detail let go over to my patreon become
a subscriber and I appreciate the
support either way I appreciate your
support I appreciate you guys watching
we're from Griffin every single week
[Music]
so you know what time it is y'all you
know what time it is
the rap Recaps
[Music]
oh ripping with Griffin
never stiffen
every Wednesday
[Music]
time for her to clap back
and that's a fact
when you lose your Fame
[__] ain't the same
but you stay in the game
that [__] was lame
get your cheese
20 slices please
then you got you on your knees
[Music]
yeah thanks for watching we're from with
Griffin y'all and I will
see you next week what happened to my
title the Tim I don't disappeared man
whatever
dear
[Music]